- Welcome back to the Kelly Clarkson Show.
I've had a great time
filling in for Kelly today,
but before we go, I have
one more story to share
from social media.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers and claps)
- Now, most things that come
out of a vending machine
are probably not that good for you.
You know, it's soda, chips, cookies.
But not this vending machine in Chicago.
It dispenses original artwork
along with vintage and nostalgic items.
Everything is $20 or less
and the machine takes credit cards.
The best part, profits go
directly to the artists.
Wonderful.
(audience cheers and claps)
So let's get the creator
of this project in here,
say hi to Steph, watching
on NBC Chicago at three.
(audience cheers and claps)
- Hi Steph.
This is such a cool idea.
So what kind of things can
you buy in this machine?
- So that's a great question.
You know, the short answer
is all kinds of things.
The main restriction is that
the machine itself is set up
to vend, like you said, a
bag of chips or a candy bar.
So it's about figuring out
how to take the artwork
that's being made and translate
it to a vendable size.
So we've had stickers,
pins, patches, bird bingo,
this is like all the birds that
you can see around Chicago,
so you can play it as you walk.
We have plant dyed scrunchies,
zines, mystery items.
I mean, truly, if you can vend it, I will.
- And where are you setting
up these vending machines?
- So right now there's two live machines
and one in the works that's being painted.
The first one ever was at
the Chicago Cultural Center,
which is like, an amazing
city arts building.
And then the second one, a
great bird-watching location,
is at Metropolitan Brewing.
So each machine is geared towards
the location that it's in.
So it's like a great
opportunity to collaborate.
It's been super fun,
not just to collaborate
with local artists and
get them an opportunity
to maybe be in front of
audiences that didn't know
that they were ready to be art shopping,
and then also a wider network of people
that are doing weird stuff
with vending machines.
There are a lot of us.
- (laughs) There are a lot
of people doing weird stuff
with vending machines? That's awesome.
My wife and I met in Chicago,
so when we're back there,
we're gonna check out
your vending machines.
Thank you, Steph.
I am liking your post right now.
(audience cheers and claps)
- And that's not all.
Kelly's season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, Steph.
So they will be writing
you a check for $1,000.
(audience cheers and claps)
- Oh my God, thank you.
- [Host] You deserve it.
Thank you to all of our
guests today, Marie Bartlett,
Annaleigh Ashford, Quentin Clare,
Ann Lauren (indistinct), and the dancers.
Kelly will be back tomorrow,
and as she always says,
have a great day, and
if it's not, change it.